I have friends who make forty two
thousand dollars a year work nine to
four but they're pumped and they'll text
me like how happy they are to be the
coach of their kids baseball team and
you know that's amazing I'm actually
weirdly envious but I have friends who
have 100 million dollars in the bank who
are still hungry who want to do even
more who will complain to me because
they know I work a lot about no work
life balance and they don't get to spend
enough time with their family and I'm
like you have a hundred million dollars
you could stay home like you're in
control don't complain about it you've
made that choice you want to spend more
time with your family spend more time
with your family